damals hatte ich mir zum edel bisschen
was zu tun auf die ich schon so ein
bisschen stand aber deshalb ist er nicht
geworden und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute heute mit max
zusammen erinnert sich ihr wisst ihr ich
bin nach köln gezogen und habe jetzt
hier keine freunde genauso wie vorher
von video leute jetzt schon gesehen wir
machen heute in geschwister takt und
zwar gibt es in diesen geschwister tag
zehn fragen die jetzt beantworten werden
übereinander ich über dich über mich
wenig los die erste frage ist ganz
einfach wer ist der ältere von uns
beiden das ist gar nicht das war alles
klar natürlich anspruch zu nehmen
das habe ich jetzt auch gerade wieder
fester verliert aber er wollte sich so
viele leute sagen dass max matter ist
der krise zu wasser am morgen geburtstag
zweite frage was magst du magst du nicht
ändern wurde
was markus markt nicht wünsch-dir-was
machen
alles war max ford um auf crack dann
übernehme ich mal wie viel max ist der
witzigste behinderte spazierten es gibt
auf der welt was mache ich noch mal ich
finde max ist sehr uneigennützig also da
hilft auch gerne mal anderen warte ich
muss sagen was man nicht an ihr okay das
passt das nicht sagen frage 3 was haben
und ein bruder gemeinsam ich glaube das
wird mal wieder von leuten hören ist
dass wir relativ wenig lachen ja ich
weiß dass hier auch gleich habe schon
erste mal dass leute sagt haye hätte gar
nicht gedacht dass wir ruhe
die augen gesehen habe da hatten wir gar
nicht mal so die gleichen augen ja aber
ich meine das passiert doch immer
deswegen weil werden die auch immer so
nach einer stunde zu haben die leute
sehen wir machen also zu egoistisch
hatte was ja das machst und dann noch
mal so dann haben schon die augen offen
anerkennt dann müssen wir sofort
beschreibt weil vorher kann man nicht
genau die leute die ihn kennen
termin das war mir noch gemeinsam wir
haben so ein bisschen sind sehr speziell
wir möchten sich bisher nur viertens
lustigste erinnerung kommunion von max
also die angewohnheit immer wieder
zusammen in der kirche sind ich weiß es
sehr unpassend damals ist also schauen
wir uns immer ganz genau so die liedtext
verhalten und neben die latics also wort
für wort weil es dich so eine uralte
altertümliche sprache ist ist das mega
löst sich immer dass man ernst nimmt und
die sache ist man sitze in der kirche
und darf nicht lachen und das macht
alles noch viel lustiger hat man den wir
nehmen sich sitzen
da guckt unruhig landesprojekt zb der
enge halle durch die engere an der jagd
wieder eine textstelle und die haben das
halt so verstanden dass der engel und es
geht halleluja klarer fall und das habe
ich dann an sebastian ist ein persönlich
habe sie gern getragen und dann haben
wir nach flash kein problem monate darf
man die schlacke alle gucken eine böse
ahnung dass mal 30 wurde auch klassiker
holt der stillen nacht hat mit wirkung
ab
maxi erzielt das ist der knabe namens
cool ist das denn geholt
fünftens einstellte der diskussion an
die man sich am meisten erinnert
vielleicht wollte ist in letzter zeit
erste gedroppt hast die beyblade sache
der wahl so ich dachte ich bin cool und
ich wollte so beyblade machen also eine
runde drehen hat den wechsel resolution
stelle dann habe ich bp täglich waschen
teilweise ein bisschen gemein dass
kinder mittelfeld da bin ich wollte der
kunstfigur zu beschleunigen
frage 6 was machen du und dein bruder um
spaß zu haben
minecraft ist dass wir das hier darf man
minecraft gespielt auf rät ihr dorf
komme oder so und ich weiß gedeckten
anleihen gruppe in dem ich gezeigt habe
da haben ja immer so geschrieben als
nenne irgendwie aus irland mit iq auf
die idee michael 2.1 experience immer
dass irland damit dort gespielt haben
vor unsere pace anstatt irgendwie jetzt
in die mitte zu fahren mit ganz vielen
fans sowieso ireland beschrieb
riesengroß bist machst du spaß zu haben
das macht richtig spaß zu haben hast du
[ __ ] manchmal nicht oder am heftigsten
lacht ich wenn ich irgend so ein text
über den ich mit max lustig machen
können das bringt nicht durch den tag
die zerstörung als dann häufig auch
immer verlassen sieben beschreibt euch
gegenseitig in einem wort
fahrkartenkontrolleur also soll jeder
achten zwar jeweils in eine freundin
oder einen freund von deinem bruder
verliebt aber meine freunde freuen also
nicht um welche person mit der darüber
zusammen ist aber so eine person mit der
manchmal
ich nicht skg ok alles klar wird ist die
geschichte heute im projekt nimmt vier
gesetzt wurde
in der folge machten damals hatte ich
mir zum edel bisschen was zu tun auf die
ich schon ein bisschen stand aber das
hat er mir nichts geworden und dann so
zwei drei monate später oder so hat max
auf einmal angefangen mit der theater da
hab ich geschrieben ich war ja mit der
freundin hat mit dem geschäft und
sebastian war traurig und ich habe
derzeit geschoben und war als quasi
immer noch in die person verlegt die
dann eigentlich eine mega viel mit max
gemacht hat dazu besuchte uns kann man
nicht im wohnzimmer saß wer von euch
hallo gesagt stell mir das liebste
insider und erklärung was es ist dann
manchmal die gruppe gruppen mit mit luca
weil du kannst nicht auch mal mit von
der partie bei den nutzen zähle also ein
running gag den wir haben oder 100 den
max hat und über die wir nicht alle
lachen ist dass er irgendwelche bilder
von irgendwelchen youtuber nimmt und
dann geht an sein handy facebook
depression und verzerrt das alles so
richtig klasse das gesicht so zwei meter
breiten zeigt das erste foto apa nicht
sofort von ihren bruder sebastian blend
euch jetzt mal das foto ahlen was ich
als echtes 52 nach dem handy wir ändern
jetzt einfach mal die fragen vom tag so
ein bisschen von zwei mal dass 2015 ich
glaube nach dem video days oder somit
rotes lokale justin
dem zuschauer das ist es was wir am ende
haben uns das ist stabil
zeitweise stand zu kriegen gilt es nun
diese stadt ist field fertig bin ja das
sind so die ältesten lustigsten bilder
die wir voneinander haben und damit auch
der geschwister tag ja was sagst du dazu
gut er was es geht sollte hier drinnen
kalabrien die kommission verweist das
geht
[Musik]